what can the human body actually do how
far can you push biology before it
breaks and we think of Batman what we
really have is the most highly trained
athlete we could ever imagine and and to
get to that level of training requires a
real constellation of things you know we
heard about the money and that's for
sure you gotta the money so you can get
the right gadgets and to add on to your
training but you have to the training
you can't just buy sports equipment and
be that superstar you've got to have
training also you can think you are but
normally you're not but Batman has to go
through the training needs a time to
find all the right teachers for all the
skills he needs and to subject himself
to like a ridiculous in science terms we
would call a really really difficult
training paradigms how do you think his
training with was it Ra's al Ghul how's
that look to you know your martial
artist yeah so you know one of the
things I liked about Batman Begins was
it did show some of the arduous nature
of the training including the kind of
beating that goes into just being
trained you know if you think that scene
in Batman Begins where he's kind of on
those postings being hit with sticks and
so on well if you got to toughen up your
body you need to toughen up your bones
too so that when you do crash into that
wall at 50 miles per hour and everything
you could so at least you can go try
including training your bones so it's a
significant you know I talked about 15
years of training to eighteen years that
would take just to get to that point
with all that and that's all part of the
training is also beating you up now how
do you strengthen the bones by hitting
the bones actually of all material yeah
what I talked about in my book was
something that's done in different
martial arts around the world like Thai
Thai kickboxing uses this some Okinawan
martial arts and some Shaolin martial
arts body conditioning we repeatedly
bang parts of the body that you're
trying to condition against the hard
object and what you do is the increased
bone density you change the
mineralization and the lines of stresses
that the bones adapt to and you make
them stronger like if you are like most
people you walk and run around but you
don't hop on your arms so the bone
density in your legs is actually a lot
higher than is New York but if you went
around training your arms you know you
get the same effect and Batman has to
train everything now you train for over
30 years haven't you I've been doing
martial arts for just over thirty years
could you be ready to take up the role
that pattern
lay down I don't think so I've been
asked that a number of times after my
book came out like this I'd say no I'm
not really interested in why it's such a
cool job you said look it I get up in
the morning I'm all beat up I can't tell
my kids where I went we're eating
breakfast I got some orange juice but my
arm is basically broken and like what's
the shelf-life of the superhero like
Batman the shelf life is like three
years three years like I'd like a like
an apple yeah it's to get that number
what I did was I looked up what's the
average career of other athletes who do
things like we see because obviously by
the way if you go to a scientific
database and type in physiology of
Batman you don't get very much so you
kind of have to come up and look outside
the lines of what other things fit
together and NFL running backs what's
average career of three years you look
at mixed martial artists their ultimate
fighters how long can they hold their
belts and be undefeated because remember
Batman can never be defeated if he's
defeated it means he's dead right so you
look at boxers when you do this you come
up with it's not a very long period of
time it's like two three years five at
the max I said I would give him ten
years if he showed up a lot of time
people just gave up
all right man's here sometimes they just
sometimes think I'm a really bad now did
you like them the first in the new movie
where he's limping around on a cane at
the very beginning of the movie it kind
of shows what might really happen a few
years down the road yeah I was really
impressed I mean I've been very
impressed with the whole arc there those
three movies are great in terms of how
to integrates lots of great concepts
from the comics with some reality around
the physicalness of what it would mean
to become Batman and what it would mean
to be Batman act as him and I think
particularly in the Dark Knight Rises we
see that that the tremendous told that
that kind of activity has and you know
if you were watching any of the Olympics
the last couple of weeks and you'd hear
some of the athletes you interviewed
they talk about how injury they are half
the time they're like well I've got this
I get this repetitive strain injury I
got this I got that I got they go out
and do what they need to do but when you
push yourself to that level it there is
a cost